>> Today, I'm pleased
to have David.
David Lomet accepted to do
this talk on cost-performance.
He gave a really
interesting talk at
the Daimon workshop, at Sigmod,
and was under a lot of
time pressure there
for obviously for
shorter presentation,
so he'll have
a little more time today
to really spell out
the details. So, Dave.
>> Thanks Phil. So, this
is my effort to give
an entertaining talk,
as well as an informative one.
We'll have to see how that goes.
So, this is pretty
much the same slides
that I used at Daimon.
So, what's happening in
traditional databases
and what's the situation
that we're facing?
So, this is a slide
that I unscrupulously
borrowed the idea from
Mike Stonebraker,
where he showed that the
traditional database systems are
being squeezed by
the special purpose datastores.
So, this is the way
the picture looks,
you got streaming on one corner,
column store on the other end and
main memory row stores
at the top,
and the situation
is perceived to be
getting even worse and these
separate areas are growing,
and the comment that
Stonebraker made
was instead of having
a one size fits all,
we have a one size fits none,
where the traditional
vendors are really
being squeezed and their markets
are being taken away,
and so this is a pretty
challenging situation.
So, the question is are
the traditional. Yes.
>> The previous slide
[inaudible].
>> In a few slides
you'll have an answer.
>> Okay.
>> So yeah. Main memory system of
the traditional vendors
maybe are dead,
and what about Amazon Aurora?
Well, they may be next.
This is not what's happening.
In fact, the elephants
are continuing to dance,
there's been no sign that
the streaming folks or
the column-store folks or
the main memory database folks,
are really taking
significant market share
from the traditional vendors,
and so the question is why?
So, here's what's happening,
you got the traditional
vendors, with streaming,
they've formed
a partnership where
streaming and traditional
database vendors
live side-by-side,
happily in peace, walking
off into the sunset.
The column store stuff has
been pretty much absorbed
into the main traditional
database engines,
and the main memory row stores,
well, they're sort of
a niche market, right?
So, the question is,
and what I'm going to
focus mostly on is
main memory row store part
and the niche market part,
and the question to
be asked is why,
why is that happening, why
has that turned out
to be the result?
So, there's economic
factors in play
and so we're working on
cloud infrastructure.
The cloud infrastructure
has to be cheap commodity.
The software infrastructure
has to run effectively
on that commodity hardware.
This is a world where there's
elastic provisioning.
That is to say, when
somebody doesn't use
the resources you
want to free them up
so that someone else
can use them instead.
You want basically
the resources to
go to the person who's got
the most money and
willing to pay for them,
and so you want to
give up resources
to higher valued applications.
So, the fact is that money talks,
it doesn't matter whether
what kind of money it is,
money talks, matters a lot.
So, what we'll see is that money
is talking very clearly
I think in this case,
and so let's proceed
and see what happens.
So, what's the story with
traditional database systems?
They're what I call
caching data stores.
They are not main memory stores,
they are caching data stores.
So, traditional database
systems actually
do offer good cost-performance.
The costs vary.
So, we need to stop being
fixated solely on performance,
we need to start thinking about
cost as well as performance.
Traditional database systems have
performance that is lower
than the main memory systems,
that's a fact of life,
and yet they succeed in having
better cost performance,
which is interesting.
Why should that be? So, what
I'm going to do is
suggest also at
the end a change in
the focus of our field to
not surprisingly be more focused
on cost performance
than pure performance.
So, caching, what is
caching data store?
Well, it uses a cache,
of course it does,
right? What is the cache?
While you move data from
secondary storage to main memory,
when the data needs
to be operated
on and you move it back
out of main memory,
when you're through using it
or when it's no longer makes
any sense to keep it in cache
because it's no longer hot.
So, it's this movement between
main memory and secondary
storage which is
the significant factor in why
the traditional database systems
are in fact still
succeeding very well.
The fact is, here the data lives
permanently on secondary
storage and it's only brought
into the main memory as
a cache improvisation where
you act on it in main memory,
and that's a very
significant factor.
So, I'm going to talk about
two forms of operation.
This is a little bit
of an abstract way of
thinking about it,
but here's what I'm going to look
at main memory operations
that we call MM,
they're operations which find
the data in main memory,
and they're very fast.
You find the data in main memory,
you just have
execution path through
your access method or whatever
and get the shovel the results
back out to our users.
The second set of
operations is what I call
secondary storage operations.
Secondary storage operations
are the ones where you
find the data on
secondary storage,
usually that means
flash nowadays,
and they're more
expensive to execute by
a not insignificant factor
than the main memory
operations are.
The reason why that is is
because we are dealing
with data that's sitting
currently on secondary storage,
you have to bring it
into memory first,
that's an operation which
costs some amount of
dollars and time,
and then you have to do
to main memory operation
after you bring the operation
into main memory.
So, that's going to be
more expensive both in
terms of performance impact
and in terms of dollars.
So, looking at it this way,
caching stores look like
a bad idea and here's
a chart which shows
why it's a bad idea.
What it shows is that as you mix
secondary storage
operations into the mix
with main memory
operations, guess what?
The performance declines.
What I've done here with
these lines is simply show
that this is a weighted average
of the operations,
and we did some experiments,
actually James did them,
which produced the results
in the dots in between,
and I summarized the
results as the ratio
between secondary
storage operations and
main memory operations
is around 5.8.
So, that says that
if you have memory on
secondary storage,
you can expect that
your performance will not be as
good as it will be if the data
is always in main memory.
>> So, what is
performance measured
as? Is that throughput?
>> Yeah. Exactly.
>> So it's relative throughput?
>> Yes that's right.
So, this looks like it
might be a performance disaster,
say each additional secondary
storage operation
pushes the performance lower,
and it pushes it
actually toward whatever
the secondary storage
operations are.
So, when you're at the,
let me go back a minute,
when you're at this end of
the graph you're getting
main memory performance,
at least for the
caching system main memory,
and at the far end you're
getting something close
to secondary storage operations.
>> Secondary storage,
you're assuming is,
so I don't mistake this.
>> I'm assuming it's flash.
So, why bother?
Why bother with caching systems?
Because costs matter.
So, now I want to take a look at,
and let's go to
the heart of the talk,
let's look at
cost performance not
just performance but
cost-performance.
There are two costs
for operating on data,
there are storage costs.
Storage costs are paid off
all the time data has
to sit some place.
Storage costs are most of
the cost for cold data.
So, what is that? Why is that?
Well, I hope you're
not operating on it,
so there's no execution cost.
So, storage cost is a factor.
Whenever you have a big factor,
whenever you have
relatively cold data.
The other cost is execution cost.
This cost is pay when you're
actually executing on the data,
and it's most of the cost of
a hot data or when
data becomes hot.
So, if you're really
banging on data very hard,
you're going to be paying
the execution cost
and this is where the main memory
systems have their advantages,
but if you're looking to
serve as cold data as well,
the cold data is
going to be sitting
on secondary storage if you have
a caching system
whereas if you have
a main memory system it's going
to be sitting in main memory,
and main memory
systems as you'll see
are more costly than
secondary storage.
So, it's about
relative costs here.
So, we have storage costs
and we have execution costs.
So, if you look at,
these are the ratios
between main memory cost
and flash storage.
There aren't any numbers here.
There were numbers
in my Daymond paper,
but there aren't any
numbers here, this is
just showing relative clause.
So, main memory is
approximately a factor of
10 more expensive than
flash memory.
On the other side when you
talk about execution cost,
these are numbers which are
derived from the BW tree.
The main memory operation is
very low cost and the flash,
executing stuff from
flash memory is very costly.
Let me come over here and
talk to you about this.
So, here's, after you bring
stuff in from flash you
have to execute on it,
so that's this cost here.
This is the cost of the IO path.
This is the cost of the processor
executing the IO instruction
going through the IO stack,
and this is the cost of buying
a secondary storage
operation on flash.
So, these operations on flash,
you have to pay for them too.
This is analogous to what
Ray talked about
when he talked about
mine disk operations in
his five minute wallpaper. Yeah.
>> Is this post analysis?
Are you considering
also the data volume?
For example, if you have
five terabytes of data,
and in memory system.
Buying a five terabyte in
memory system is going
to be inordinately more
expensive than a 100 gigabyte in
memory system per
gigabyte, right?
Whereas you can easily have
a five terabyte MVM system
which is more or less
commodities this days.
So, I think the price
also probably starts
increasing as soon,
if you want go with
larger data volumes.
>> There's any number of
ways of making this more complex.
>> Okay. So, assuming
the standard like
maybe 100 gigabytes
or that kind of data type.
>> This is sort of a standard
commodity prices out there.
>> Okay.
>> So, either the relative costs
and I'll have some more things
to say about that later,
and the reason why,
so previously it used to cost
you a lot to buy an IO axis
but the current
assets deeds give you
hundreds of thousands of IOPS,
and so the end result is
that that drives down
the cost of buying
IOPS substantially.
So, this is the cost of buying
one IO operation, executing. Yes.
>> So, on the left and
right the cost are
of different units.
So, om the left is kind of.
>> Yeah. They're
not the same units.
That's right. These are
just relative numbers.
Relative numbers here,
relative numbers there.
>> Yes. So, I'm just trying to
say like on the left side
you are counting dollars,
how many like money
or pay for a storage?
>> I'm counting dollars
on the right as well.
>> All right. So, how
do you calculate?
>> Well, by how much of
the processor you consume
when doing your execution.
>> Okay.
>> Or how much of the essence
these IOPS chainability you buy.
So, it's cost on both sides.
Okay. So, we compute
cost plotted against
operations per second.
So, here I'm going
to explain to you,
I'm going to show you.
This is the math that's
probably the only math I'm
still capable of doing,
but here's the math involved.
So, the cost will turn out
to be a linear function
of the storage and
execution costs and here's
what it looks like.
So, here's the linear function.
So, your cost per second
is what we're going to calculate,
equals A which is the cost for
renting the storage for
that period of time,
plus B which is the cost per
operation times the number
of operations you're executing.
So, what's going
to happen is that,
what we're going to show is
that this is a class
which you always pay,
and this is a class
but you pay based on
how many operations per
second you are executing.
Now, this I hope is clear
because I'm going to
depend upon this analysis
in the rest of the talk.
So, what is a storage cost?
It's cost per byte times
the size of the data.
Again, the interesting
thing here is that
DRAM costs 10 times
the cost of the flash.
When you're executing
no operations,
storage cost is the entire cost
of managing the data.
You'll see when I talk,
when I show the graph
in the next slide,
you'll see that it's the
Y-intercept in the graph one.
Over here, over in this end
when zero operation is going.
Execution cost is
whatever the cost per
operation is and that's what I
showed you in the previous slide,
that what's the cost
per operation
times the number of operations
per second we're executing.
So, remember that now what,
and the graph that I showed
before that the secondary
storage operation,
it's a factor of 12 or so more
expensive than the main memory
operation because you have
to buy the I/O path
and you have to buy
the IOPS from from
the from the SSD.
So, so, this this cost,
if you go back here,
this cost determines
the scope of the line.
So, this is, again,
a little linear equation which
relates the costs of
the various pieces to
the total cost that you face.
And so, here's the graph.
Over on this side where
there's zero operations,
the cost is all the storage cost
and here you can see
that storage costs
for main memory
is a factor of 10 more than
the cost of the secondary
storage operation.
Now, as you go to the
to the to the right,
this goes up by a factor
of 12 faster than this-
this secondary storage operation
goes up by a factor of
12 faster than the main
memory operation does.
So, not surprisingly,
at some point they meet
and that's what
Gray's five-minute rule
showed except that
the computation
suggested it's now around
one minute largely again because
SSDs produce so many more IOPS.
Little thing about
data caching systems is that
they had the opportunity
to choose the lower level,
lower lower cost operation.
Now, nobody does
this precisely but
the potential goes that
we all sort of try to
get good caching
policies so that we
approximate this curve
where we're always using
the lowest cost operation
to manage our data.
>> [inaudible] can't you get
the red line performance with
caching if you have the locality?
>> I'm trying-
>> So if you have an extremely
high cache out rate then-
>> Well, then you are
operating over here.
Okay? This is the IOPS
per second area,
this is the low ops
per second area.
By definition, you're having
low hit ratio on
this side whereas you're
having high hit ratio-
>> Hits per second, I get it.
>> Yes.
>> Got it.
>> Okay. So, that's why,
that's the additional degree
of freedom that
caching systems have versus
the other kinds of systems.
So, what about
the other kinds of systems?
Now I'm going to have-
there's two comparisons
I'm going to
talk about and one is
main memory systems, okay?
So, main memory system
their performance is better
than caching system
and indeed the,
their performance is better
than a fully cached
caching system.
There's a lot of paths that
they don't have to execute.
They can use specific and
more tightly bound to
main memory the assumption that
all the memories
all the data is in memory.
So, they in fact have
a better performance.
So, here's the comparison.
So, mastery has
higher performance
than the Deuteronomy's Bw-Tree.
It executes at around 2.6 or
so factor faster than
the Bw-Tree does.
It turns out it takes,
and this is sort
of interesting, it
takes in main memory now,
it takes around 2.3
times the amount of
storage that the main that
that the Bw-Tree takes.
So, well, one thing that we're-
so I'll have qualifiers on
this a little bit later.
So, what does that mean?
So, that means that you've got
this cost graph here, again,
remember this is our old
secondary storage operation
with a rising very sharply.
This is the the
Deuteronomy curve
where- main memory curve
where it goes up slowly.
And this is the, this is the
the mashtree way up here.
Notice its costs in terms of
storage is approximately
twice the cost of
the of the Bw-Tree
and it goes up very,
very slowly, right?
And where it crosses
is that around
a hit ratio of once every
three seconds for a 4K page.
This ratio over here is
about one minute when
you cross between
the secondary storage operation
and the Deuteronomy
main memory operation.
So, your data has to be really
hot in order for
you to profit from
the higher performance of
mashtree at least in terms
of its cost implications.
So, Deuteronomy's cost
performance is better
all the way over to
the three second point
and that's the region
where the mashtree is
better if you've
got super hot data.
But unlike the case where
we're switching here
between main memory operations
and secondary storage operations,
there's no switching between
the Bw-Tree and mashtree.
You're sort of committed
one way or the other.
So you have to be prepared to
to choose which system
you're going to use
from the start.
So, I think I did
a little calculation here.
So, if you're executing on
a 40 gigabyte database,
then you have to be executing
at least three million
operations per second
before you're better
off in terms of
cost by using by
using the mastery.
All right. So, there's
another aspect and this is
another system I wanted
to compare with,
although this is much
more hypothetical,
we did no experiments on this.
It's Facebook pro- yeah?
>> [inaudible] So,
how are you talking
about times here like
one minute and three seconds?
What are what are
those, what are those?
>> Those are the- that's
the interval between operations,
the head interval for
a piece of data and it's
using a 4K page is only a matter
of trying to measure
the the general same- what
the temperature is of the data
on a particular page.
Again, with the Bw-Tree
versus mashtree.
You don't really have
that choice, right?
And the mashtree is
paginated anyway.
But this gives you
an idea of what
the relative temperatures
are of these things.
>> Thanks.
>> Okay. So, now,
what about people who
have enormous amounts
of data like Facebook?
Facebook had a really bad
problem because they wanted
good performance on cold data
and they were
worried about costs.
>> So, they were in such a
bad shape that they
were actually,
but this is a side year paper
from a couple of years ago.
I should have properly
included a reference to it,
but they were buying
more processors,
not because they needed
they were buying more processors
so that they could attach
more SSDs to accommodate
the huge volume of data.
>> Processors or
more PCI connections
or what would the bottleneck
with the CPU time or?
>> No, it was just
conductivity to the boxes.
>> What could I mean like
going to be solved by putting
more coordinates in
the CPU or do you need to
have more motherboards
with more PCI connections.
>> You need to be able
to attach more SSDs.
I don't know what
the answer is beyond that.
>> Okay.
>> I think there's, in
the commodity space,
I think when you buy boxes,
you're limited to
how many connections
you can make to the SSDs.
>> Okay. So, in that case,
they were marked
really low power CPUs,
but lots and lots of them.
>> Yeah.
>> Okay.
>> That was a good
position they were in.
>> Okay.
>> Okay. So, what
was their solution?
Well, they were using
a data caching system,
and what to that they added
data compression as well.
Okay. So, they
needed low latency,
so to use SSD storage,
and they scaled out the
processes for good performance,
and then they use
data compression
to lower their storage costs.
So, what were they doing in
this model of performance
that I've been showing you?
Okay. So, let me
walk through this.
This is our old number on
secondary storage operations.
This is the number for
the Deuteronomy's main,
BW freeze main memory operations.
This is where they
meet way out there.
So, what am I showing
with this purple line?
This purple line is
a secondary storage operation,
which features compressed data.
So, this is all hypothetical,
I don't have access to
the details of Facebook members,
but the attempt was
for me to show was
that here when you're
using compressed data,
you start way down
here because you're
saving storage costs, right?
Because you've just squeezed
your storage costs way down
because you're using
only some fraction
of the storage that
you're using before,
let's say it's one-third.
So, this is going to be
one-third the storage cost
of the uncompressed data
sitting on secondary storage.
So, you're saving on
storage costs here.
Remember this is
where the data is
not being used at all, okay?
But now, when you
start using the data,
and you start accessing it,
you bring it into memory,
now you have to start
paying the cost of
not only the IO
path and the IOPS,
you have to pay the cost of
the CPU compressing and
decompressing the data as well.
>> Can you compress speed memory?
>> Well, yes you
could. Sure. Sure.
>> Would that be in
the middle triangle then or?
>> Well, if you compressed
on main memory using this curve,
that would be to lower the cost
here and raise the slope.
Okay. So, when you compress,
you lower the storage cost,
but increase the slope
because you're paying
an execution cost. Yeah.
>> So, I'm wondering
for the memory systems,
you mean all the data
have to be in the memory?
>> Yes.
>> So, there are
some techniques you have in you
and Microsoft have these Siberia
technique form [inaudible].
>> Yes.
>> You can support code data on
secondary storage for
our my email off my database,
whether you don't measure
the costs for that kind
of technique?
>> So, to a first approximation,
nobody uses systems that way.
I know, so Siberia was
a research project.
It's not part of
Microsoft's product.
What they've done,
this a complex space,
and I've obviously simplifiable.
But what they've done
is they've embedded
Hekaton code into
the larger SQL server.
So, if you have Hekaton tables,
you can execute
Hekaton code on it,
but the data has to
be in main memory.
If you have tables which
are resident on
secondary storage,
then you have to use
the traditional sort of
classic SQL Server
engine on that.
You can do joins, cross them,
but you're committed to one
or the other depending upon
how you define your tables.
>> Sure.
>> So, but I don't know of
anybody who actually uses,
Solberg had a paper
on anti-caching also.
All these efforts, starting with
main memory database technology
aren't really designed
to have most of
the data sitting on
secondary storage.
So, those papers are all
written in the following style.
If the data is too big
to fit in main memory,
we'll let some of it drift
off to secondary storage.
But that's not what
I'm saying here.
What I'm saying here is,
you want to push data
out of main memory,
when it's not cost effective
to leave it there,
and that could happen long before
you run out of main memory
because you're going
to free up main memory for
somebody who has
a higher use for it.
>> Yes.
I have a question about
the page for example.
So, is the fact that most
of the data is core.
Is that a function of
the volume of the data
or is something like LinkedIn,
is LinkedIn mostly towards
secondary storage or?
>> Yes.
>> Okay.
>> Yeah, they're all some of
that. There's too much data
stored in main memory.
Facebook, even Mohan can't
keep Facebook data
hot, enough up.
I mean I thought that.
>> They have hash tables on secondary
storage or the [inaudible]?
>> I don't know. I mean,
I don't know the details
of how Facebook works.
>> There is two interesting
things about Facebook.
One of them is that when
you put something on there,
you never delete it, so it
gets very old and very cold.
Second, everything
you put on there is
like 300 megabytes in size,
everything you put
on Facebook is quite
large. Tell me which one was?
>> So, either way,
they've got to push it
out of main memory.
They only want to use
main memory when they
need it to actually
execute on the data.
>> This paper that describes
this secondary storage
architecture is very cold data.
>> Okay. Yeah. Datamo
is really cold.
>> I remember exactly where
it appears [inaudible].
>> For Facebook?
>> It's cold.
For Facebook. Yeah.
>> Okay. I think they
use artificial medium.
>> I think they use
some archival medium
of some sorts. So, when they-
>> Yeah, very cost conscious
on the cold data. Sure.
>> Yeah, yeah. So, Mohan's data
will never be on
archive or media,
but it will not be kept in
storage, in main memory.
>> Mohan might be posing more
of a screening value because I
think it's still gets cold,
it's just more images, more cold
data. You also stream [inaudible].
>> Okay. I don't want to
let this go on too far.
It's a little bit
unfair, but it's fun.
For those of you who don't know,
I'm not a friend of Mohan.
For most of us, he is the person,
the friend of ours who posts
most frequently on Facebook.
>> Yeah, okay.
>> Am I right?
>> So, I went to work
today. How nice.
>> So, this looks like
a very small area
from which you're
gathering return on actually
using depression, but it isn't.
I just use the 80-20 but
the ratios between
hot and cold data
could be enormous, right?
So, mostly data is
in fact sitting out
here in most applications
and you're bringing data into
main memory when
it's hot. All right.
So, how do you
make a high-performance and
low-cost data caching system?
Where am I? So, this
is can be very short.
So, it's going to go by
quickly and it's not
animated in any way.
So, you're going to have to
read it with me. All right.
So, what does it
take to optimize the cost
of the data caching system?
Well, so one thing is obvious.
One way to reduce
the cost is simply
increase it's main memory
performance, right?
As I indicated before,
if you have a high performance,
the higher your performance
in main memory,
the higher your performance of
the main memory portion of
that curve will be. All right.
So, that's one thing you can do
but you need scalability as well.
So, it's not just performance,
you need to be able to scale
up performance as well.
That's tricky and
the main memory database spokes,
I guess including us a bit,
to have a tripped all over
themselves trying to get
scalable performance out of
these multi-core systems
and it's hard.
We have thread-safe
conflict free code
that we execute
all over the place
where one thread can
execute any code.
Other people try
partitioning where you
get better performance but
have a harder time scaling,
because things cross
partition boundaries
and once you cross
partition boundaries,
your performance time.
So, it's hard to get,
but this is one of
the things you can do.
If you want to prove
cost performance,
you improve performance
in main memory.
That's one of the
thing you can do.
Second is you can reduce
the number of IOs.
Well, you say, "Well, okay,
what does that mean?"
That mean we are always trying to
just do the IOs randomly that
are only that are required.
Well, so when is an IO required?
So, one of the things
that's a property
of both what we do in
Deuteronomy system
and what RocksDB
does is we support BlindWrite.
What is a BlindWrite?
A BlindWrite is I'm going
to update sometimes called
the virus into an upsert.
Doesn't matter what
the state of the object
was before, it wasn't objects.
We're going to create
something and put it in
the new state of
the object regardless
of what the old state was.
So, you don't have to look at
the old state to
perform this operation.
If you don't require that the
operation changes data
in place someplace.
So, in RocksDB world,
they have a local in-memory
table which they'll update.
For us, we do an update by
posting a delta update to
our mapping table in memory.
So, a BlindWrite don't
require access to get
the data to put the stuff
in the right place.
Another thing here is,
what do I want to talk about
here? Block structuring.
This is true again in a way
with both RocksDB and
with our stuff which
is you take the pressure off
the right side of it by only
supporting large writes.
So, you have a small number
of very large writes
that you do as
the characteristic of
what block structuring does.
You have these enormous buffers
and you write them out.
Instead of having to write
out every single page
individually where
you have to execute
the IO code path
in the processor,
you don't have to buy
an extra eye app on the SSD.
That reduces your costs
and improves
your performance as
well on the right path.
The third thing is
having a record cash.
So, all these numbers that
I've shown you are mostly
show what the relative costs
are or what the
relative access rates
are for using a 4K page.
But the smaller the memory unit
that you're looking at,
the longer you can afford to keep
that unit in main memory.
So, if you have a record cache,
and you can be more
selective as well.
So, if you have a record cache,
you can keep that record
in main memory
longer than you can
a paginated store which
contains a lot of
extra data. So,
that's another thing.
Frankly both RocksDB and
us we do Deuteronomy stuff
do that in a certain
different ways,
but we both do it, right?
We do it by keeping
our data updates around.
We also do it by having
a record cache at our
transactional component as well.
So, having records as
opposed to pages helps.
We also have pages.
So, we have a page cache
as well as those RocksDB,
but the fact that
you have a record cache
means that you can
keep the data around
longer in main memory
and get better performance
out of it as well.
You can reduce data movement cost
between secondary
storage and main memory.
Bunch of ways to do that,
one way is make the IO paths
shorter by using
a user-level IO that cuts
out the operating system,
puts you in charge of the
cache of the scheduling.
If you buy one newer SSDs
which support
larger number of eye apps,
then that'll drive the cost
down for eye apps as well,
or you can do what we're
trying to do this summer
which is to change
what the SSD does.
Thus they change what they
SSD controller does sort
of interface when you
pass that back and forth
between the interface,
you lower the cost.
I'm not going to talk
about that in detail
because Yvonne is going to
talk about that next week,
but it involves getting
in my world down and
dirty with the SSD.
Thankfully, Yvonne has
a little bit more experience
with that dirty part of
the system than I do.
So, we can like him for
doing the right stuff.
Then finally, you can reduce
the cost of secondary storage.
So, I've talked about
compressing data.
That's obviously
one way to do it.
That raises your operation cost,
but it's certainly reduces
your storage costs.
Here's a gratuitous comment
which is that I don't think that
MV RAM is going to carry
the day because it's a cost.
They don't tell you what
the cost is but that's
a sure sign to cost more
than I'd like you to now.
So, it's a factor of three or so,
I'm guessing, more expensive
than flash memory.
So, used as a SSD technology
doesn't look so attractive to me.
You can also say, "Well,
what about reducing
secondary storage costs
by using disks?"
You can do that too. You can
use even tape as well, right?
So, if you've got
cold enough data and you don't
have stringent access times
requirements to get to it,
then that's what you
should be doing, right?
Because when the access rate
is low enough,
the overwhelming part of
the costs that you're
facing is the storage costs
which can be enormous.
So, you want to drive
that storage costs
down appropriate with the level
of heat that you
find in your data.
So, that's how you make
a good cost performance.
So, couple of caveats.
Our numbers are
approximate, right?
So, all of this
and I'll show you how
they are approximate.
So, performance at baseline
set of point experiments
executed on our machines
using mostly are
Deuteronomy system.
So, you generalize it
at some risk but
I think they tell a story
that's interesting.
The costs are taken from the web.
I scoured the web
looking for cost.
They vary a lot even in
one instant of time and are
changing over time, right?
So, it's not something
which is etched in stone
here like that your
next comment on
the Amazon gravestone.
It's not etched in stone.
But, I think that
the general thrust of
results gives you a good way
of thinking about
how to design your system and why
data caching systems are
in fact a very good idea.
So, that's one caveat.
Second caveat is
best cost performance is
not the only thing that
you need to worry about.
Okay. Maybe it may not
even be the primary thing
that you worry about.
So certainly, it's always
the case that low cost is a plus.
But, what you want to maximize
is not minimizing cost.
You want to maximize value
which is the difference
between what
you earn from processing
the data and what
it cost you, right?
So, if you've one of
these applications which has
really high value tremendous
needs for low latency,
maybe you don't want to
use a data caching system.
Maybe that's the niche where
a main memory stuff
makes sense, right?
Because they've got
very high cost,
but if the value is
enormous and the value
comes from your being,
just a little bit faster
than the other guy,
then you may be willing to spend
a whole lot more money and not
worry so much about
the lowest cost.
So, somebody stock trading things
are of that flavor but
it's not a whole lot.
I think the vast majority
of the applications
are more concerned
with some sort of thing which
is suitable for
an interactive system.
Now, there's
an enormous spectrum not
trying to say that
there's anything
in between because there is,
but you have to
decide which place
your system fits in that.
Generally speaking, trying
to minimize your cost,
maximize your cost performance
is a goal that most people,
and certainly the
traditional systems,
should be aiming at as a way
to keep the majority of
their customers happy. All right.
So recap, this is
the critical thing.
I just want to remind you.
There's two costs, storage
cost and execution cost.
You always pay the storage cost,
even if nothing's
happening on your data.
So that's a really
significant aspect of that.
So, if nothing is
happening on your data,
you want to work as hard as you
can to reduce the storage costs.
So, when data is cold,
storage cost is most of the cost.
When data is hot, then you say,
well, okay execution cost
really starts to matter here.
But most data, most
of the time is cold.
They win by moving data
between the low-cost medium,
which doesn't have
as much performance
but has a higher cost
of operation.
They move it from there to
the high-cost medium,
main memory,
which is higher cost on a sort
of a time basis for
the storage but it has
a lower execution cost,
and you switch between the two
based on what you approximate
to be the crossover point.
So, the moral is this,
we should be focusing on
data caching systems
and their improvements.
>> [inaudible] data
caching system?
>> Yes.
>> Okay.
>> So, this, I can't leave you
without getting in a plug
from our advertisers.
This talk is brought
to you by Bw-Tree
in production it's in SQL Server.
It's only main memory part,
it's an Azure Document DB
i's the one that makes it
possible for- it's
now called Cosmos DB.
It makes it possible for them to
offer immediate indexing of
documents which are just loaded.
This is a real problem because
what happens when
a document comes in,
it has index terms from all
over the key space and if you
try to update the whole
key space immediately,
you end up touching all the data
and having to bring it all in.
This is an example where
the blind rights and
being able to execute code
which does blind rights,
which don't require putting
this stuff all the way home in
the original secondary storage
location, matters a lot.
Then Bing's ObjectStore is
another place where we're used.
And there are some references.
Thank you for your time.
The top references
is the daemon stiff.
It's actually, I
found out something
interesting when I submitted
my paper to daemon.
I think this is ACM, maybe it's
ACM general policy
but they offer you
the option of retaining
copyright to your article
and just giving them use,
certain kind of fair use,
and what you lose on that
is they won't defend
your copyright like they
would if you turn
the copyright over to them.
But it seems to my tests,
my brief test of it,
it seems to permit you to
go to ACM's website and
download the document without
having to cross their paywall.
So, that I thought was
sort of interesting.
maybe they only offer
it on workshops
and not in their conferences.
But anyway, I chose to make
it more widely available.
So you can freely download
it from this. Yeah?
>> What about hard drives.
Hard disk drives where does
that fit in on- there's
a lot that's been done on
producing low cost
hard-drive systems
with the expectation
that they're going to
be used for very cold data,
just other layer
in the hierarchy.
>> Yes. Yeah. So, I think that's
exactly the right way to
look at it and, you know,
I think this is true
of Socrates that
a lot of the data is
as on our disk
but when they're actively
running with data,
they actually store
a lot of it on SSDs.
So they stage it and I think
that multi-level hierarchies
are an interesting way.
It's more complicated system.
Every time you introduce
an extra layer in the system,
the system becomes that
much more complicated.
But there's money at
stake so going back for
instance to NB RAM technology,
I don't think that
NB RAM is going to play
a big role in the SSD
market but I haven't ruled
out the fact that it might
play an interesting role as
simply a memory extension where
it's actually cheaper
than main memory,
than DRAM and of course it has
the durability property,
but it's slower as well.
So, it too has- I can
imagine you coming up with
a similar kind of curve
to what I've shown here,
which talks about when
you should migrate data
between your cold
main memory store and
your hot main memory
store and I think
that same sort of
reasoning applies to
that case except that the cost of
moving the data between
the two is a lot lower.
So I think that makes
a perhaps reasonably
attractive package to go for.
But in terms of an
SSD replacement,
I don't think that- I mean until
it's trying to sell it for
that but I don't think so.
>> Your numbers, you're only
showing less than a 6X difference
between SSD and DRAM
and you're trying to put
something in between.
You don't have a lot of
flexibility, there to deal with.
I mean there has to
be data that has
the right access rate inward
and size in order to
benefit from having
something in
that narrow slot, right?
>> I don't think it's
as narrow as you think.
So, what the lower cost would be,
I think that the cost difference
between DRAM and main
memory in-between-.
>> Halfway in between.
>> It would be about halfway
in between which is about
a factor of three I
think in each direction.
So, what you're seeing is
a curve which starts here, right?
Which starts substantially
below this, right?
It has a curve on what
its cost increases are and
its costs increases
in terms of executed.
It's rather slope because
the cost of executing that
doesn't include an L path,
doesn't include buying an I/O op
and so it sort of
increases more gradually,
so I think that you might see
that this goes up over
to here someplace,
in terms of the times at which
it's lower cost operation.
Now, all this is
hypothetical because
nobody's built a system
quite like that yet,
but I think that's
an interesting thing to pursue.
We're simply pursuing
it in terms of
replacing flash storage with it.
All you do is add
a factor of three or
so to the memory class
and you don't change
this line at all,
because you still have the IO
access time and blah blah blah.
So, you've got to think
about it in terms
of how the entry comes in,
in terms of what
both its storage costs
are and its execution cost. Yeah?
>> So you're basically
saying that the green line
will be shallower?
>> Yes, that's right. Yes. If you
use it as the main
remedy extension.
>> Okay.
>> Yeah?
>> These co-processors
like GPUs or
VGAs seems like the an operation.
That party might be affected.
I'm wondering which way does that
go. Make this shallower?
>> I have no idea.
>> [inaudible]
>> I think the important thing
with those sort of things is
how much prep time you
need versus how much
gain you get, right?
And if you can reduce
the prep time,
same way if you can reduce
the amount of code
you have to execute
the dual I/O operation,
that means you can afford
more I/O operations.
If you can reduce the amount
of prep time that you need,
amount of computation you need
for prepping those devices.
Then, you can use
a more frequent.
But I don't have
any great insights.
>> Decompression at VGA, right?
>> Yeah, compression is the
obvious place it might matter.
>> Anything else? What
about power cost?
Have you done- have you
looked at that at at all?
People talk so much
about the importance
of how our efficiency
in the data center.
Is that a factor here
do you think or no?
I mean that was more
obvious because you're
spinning this physical thing.
This is all semiconductor.
>>Yeah, so even with
hard drives once you've
got things spinning,
it was the movement of
the arm which was most
of the power cost.
With SSDs, the power is only
based on the access rates.
It's a stable [inaudible].
But I don't know. What about
the cost of building
the facility?
What about the cost of getting
the customers to use-
there is a lot of costs.
I think the interesting
thing here though,
is you've got something which
has sort of a component which
has a multiplicity of
uses and its cost,
if you can isolate its costs,
you can in fact compare
costs between one
thing and the other.
If the application has
this enormous path
through it before you
get to the data cashing
store one form or another
and it has this long path,
then most of the cost is going
to be consumed in
the application,
and so maybe the
data management cost
don't matter all
that much anyway.
But I don't think
you can think that.
I don't- I think that's
a- if you go down
that path too far,
we end up saying cost
doesn't matter any place.
So, you need to start taking
costs seriously
everywhere, right?
One of the things
the hackathon people found,
was they did this storage engine
which was an enormously
faster than anything
that they had before.
Then they found, well,you know we
have the performance
impact of that on
the whole database engine
is 15 percent, right?
Or 20 percent, right?
You need to be able to
attack the entire path
in order to be able to
have a significant impact
on overall performance,
and that's true costs as well.
So, but I don't do
the rest of the stack so
like we're only talking
about data management.
So, thank you all for listening.